hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become I'm Joanna and today's workout
is a chest and but toning workout so we
want to work on both your chest and butt
and tone and firm them up so this
workout will be based on repetitions the
goal is to complete 12 to 15 repetitions
for each workout and what you'll need is
a pair of lightweight dumbbells between
two to three kilos each if you don't
have a pair of dumbbells where you can
use it's a pair of water bottles ok so
let's start by doing some warmups
then shoot it with the pod with your
toes pointing forward and just give me
some really easy squats to warm your
body up good so squat down and up okay
just wake those muscles up the more
squats you do I want you to go deeper so
squat low up push your butt back and
come back up and squeeze your gluts good
chest open back straight and just
squeeze your glutes right at the top
very nice so dig deeper and up down and
up good few more down and up down and up
and now take a wider step again squat
down but this time you will feel more on
your inner thighs as well as the outer
part of your glutes so toes pointed out
squat down
push it squeeze the glutes right at the
top okay so up squeeze bring it back
down up and squeeze good give me five
more down it up let's warm the legs and
your butt good it up last one down and
up now just stand right at the edge of
the mat what I want you to do is start
by getting into in
to choose a push-up a case of inch
forward give me a nice push up an inch
back and stand up and back down good so
keep the leg spread into a nice push up
and back nice up down again forward and
push up give me two more okay keep your
legs straight stretch out your
hamstrings down push up and go back last
one more go back down push it up and
rest it off okay now just lie on the
floor let's work on some bridges so bend
your knees toes points are forward and I
want to just lift your butt off squeeze
it and bring it back down lift it up
squeeze it and bring it back down lift
it up squeeze hold it back down up and
squeeze good let's aim for eight more
down up squeeze this is two part of your
warm up down up and squeeze last three
more up squeeze last two more hold it
squeeze last one all the way up squeeze
as high up as possible and back down
very good now let's get back up and
let's start with the first workout which
is a squat to a lunch okay so let's
start with our right leg what I wanted
to do is stand sugar with a pot toes
pointed forward get into a nice deep
squat and bring your right leg back into
a lunge okay so that's one on each side
and we want to aim for traffic
repetitions on the right side and switch
over ready let's go down to squat and
back into a lunge squat down and back
good so maintain a low position that way
you will be engaging
looks as well as your legs good keep it
down
that's five let's go for chop good you
should feel your left leg burning five
more down and back
white step back last three more white
step back plus two more and one more
do you feel that burn just on one cheek
right here okay now swap over switch
side and now let's bring your left leg
back
okay ready squat down bring it back and
squat down so just small gentle pulses
and bring it back good now you should
feel the burn on your right side very
nice
let's go for seven more okay back six
more back that's five keep your knees
Bend keep going white lunch let's go for
four more white squat down deep plus
three last two more one more
whoop I can feel the burn and shake it
very good oh so that was a really good
workout for your legs and a butt as well
now let's get down onto all fours okay
so what a way to do is all false a
floating kickback so onto all fours tuck
in your toes lift your body up hover
just about two inches off the mat and I
wait to pick one leg back point it in
and take it back okay so we want to work
on one side first and then switch over
ready 12 on each side okay right up
hover let's go keep it back bring it in
kick it back keeping your body in a
straight line okay do not take it back
or do not arch your back good take
squeeze your glutes bring it in squeeze
that's five good kick it do not dip your
hips to one side as well
good keep going squeeze whoa quick
squeeze straight back nice for more kick
three plus two one more and kick now
let's switch on the opposite side so
lift yourself up and now on the right
leg in and squeeze your glutes good
three four push into the ground okay
five six kick we can use seven good 8/9
kick last three more ten plus two more
one that's one more two and just relax
and shake it off right next workout my
favourite single leg push up to downward
dog right if this is too challenging
remember you can always start on your
knees first
okay so let's start in a high plank what
I weight to do is start in a high plank
lift one leg off get into a push-up as
you come up kick back into a high
downward dog okay
and bring your body down another push-up
and kick it back okay
so we want to aim for six on each side
kick it back three good so strong legs
strong chest strong core good five nice
one more six kick it back and let's
switch over so now the opposite leg up
push up kick it back as high as I can
squeeze your glutes right at the top
squeeze the right but right at the top
and down three into a push-up as low as
you can
four nice up last two five one more very
good shake it out a little bit and now
for the next workout what you'll need is
a pair of lightweight dumbbells okay so
grab your dumbbells or if you don't have
a pair of dumbbells you can use a pair
of water bottles so light down alright
what I wanted to do is a chest press
okay so get into a nice high bridge all
right squeeze and hold this position
maintain this position squeezing your
glutes spread your arms by your side
in line with the chest level alright
gently tap the elbows on the floor lift
it up squeeze it into a chest press
lower it back down do not rest your arms
tap it and press it back up okay
so we want to aim for twelve to fifteen
repetitions three squeeze the chest
right at the top bring your chest
muscles together for remember to always
lift lift lift your butt okay do not
drop it lift it up five good give me
fifteen okay six nice so you're working
both on your chest and your butt at the
same time
seven squeeze suck your belly in it ah I
can feel my bad burning nine and your
chest at the same time
five more one tab do not rest two three
squeeze tighten your abs for one more
down and up five good now just drop your
weights and just shake it out a little
bit we want to get into glute bridge
much all right so shake it out a little
bit
place both hands by your sides
all right now I wait to live again lift
your butt up I get into a nice high
bridge position and with glute bridge
March what you want to do is lift one
leg off March and then alternate with
the other leg okay so left and right is
one all right
let's aim for fifteen good three lift it
off
and remember do not drop okay this is
wrong so high up five March
squeeze your gluts six good eight nine
good ten you should feel your glutes
working one two and just look straight
ahead
three squeeze for one more five and drop
back down very nice you have one more
workout okay flying crunches okay
this is a really fun workout to do right
so grab both dumbbells or you can even
do this workout without any weights
again bend your knees toes pointed
forward start with both dumbbells up
give me a nice chest fly open up spread
your wings bring it together okay and
what I wait to do is draw both dumbbells
back into a pullover as you come up give
me a high crunch okay a nice crunch
again open spread your elbows bring it
together extend pull over and crunch up
good got that movement so spread it
together extend and crunch that's three
nice spreaded bend your elbows slightly
pull it over keeping it I was soft but
do not bat it too much okay so you
should aim for your arms to be as
straight as possible
good let's go five bring it in you
should feel the stretch along your chest
nice six up crunch good feel your apps
your lower and your upper abs working as
well pull over and up seven keep going
extend eight nice I love this workout
it's like killing three birds with wings
crunch it extend pull over up nice last
four more kqp for more pull and crunch
it up go as high as you can it spread
your wings as wide as possible and pull
as far back as you can last two more
spread pull as far back as you can up
last one more spread it middle pull as
far back and up good job
now drop both dumbbells and get back up
that was your first round done breathe
drink some water
wipe your sweat we have two more sets to
go you are strong keep it up
okay drink some water keep yourself
hydrated
good now that you know all the exercises
for the second set I want you to push
yourself even more if you want to in
four more repetitions go for 15 reps and
just really engage your muscles and get
your core muscles your butt muscles and
your chest muscles okay
remember that proper form is extremely
important so always keep your chest open
your back flat do not hunt at any point
all right so let's start with the first
workout which is squat to lunch okay
let's start with our right leg back all
right ready
let's go toes forward squat down up and
lunch back you down and that next let's
go for fifteen okay three nice wide step
back for five nice there you go you
should feel nice like burning six seven
hook stay low stay low
eight nine I can feel your bird ten five
more let it burn
one two three last two you are strong
four last one more and who we got to
balance it out with at the other side
because we have two legs okay so you
shake it out a little bit now let's
bring your left leg back and work on
your right leg
ready let's go squat down up bring it
back up and back good again 24:15 three
four five whew that's squeeze here six
seven good halfway there eight do not
come up right now nine
10 when it's burning hole it one do you
that intensity 2 3
last one for one more 5 and shake it out
oh my god no let's get back down all
fours floating kicks okay let's get onto
all fours
choose which size you want to start off
with all right nice firm grip press into
the floor
hover let's go one leg back kick back
squeeze your glutes kick back squeeze it
bring it back squeeze and back good four
five good six squeeze let's go for
fifteen seven eight push through the
heels
nice breeze ten last five more one to
straight legs okay not too high up three
four
last one and five good right shake it a
little bit now let's work on the other
side let's go
hover up one push it back squeeze - good
you should feel that one leg should be
stronger than the other four five steady
strong core six seven eight breathe
five more see a sweat dripping one to
press into the floor three last two four
plus one and five good well done alright
third workout single egg push up to
downward dog
now let's aim for 7 repetitions on each
side ok so start in a high plank if you
feel like oh my god I need to catch my
breath then stop for a little while
catch your breath and join me back here
to the workout ok let's go
so left leg up ok good now let's get
into push up and take it back squeeze
your left cheek and bring it back
high up good we're aiming for seven on
each side three four very nice five as
low as I can with a push up six last one
seven and up good job now switch over
ready let's go up right leg up nice
solid blue shop keep back
if you have to start on your knees and
kick it back okay choose your option
three four three more five you are
strong plus two last one come on come on
last one push up and take it back very
good
alright now let's lie on the floor and
do bridge chest press
so grab your dumbbells okay choose your
option you do what the challenge
yourself go for heavier dumbbells or go
lighter right place your body adjust a
position bend your knees twist pointed
forward leave the dumbbells up ready
lift your butt up maintain this position
throughout dump us up and now let's go
elbows tap on the floor push up and a
Gabriel great for 15 always remember to
squeeze squeeze and squeeze your gluts
do not drop it down four tap five spread
it out bend your arms 90 degrees six
okay spread it wide seven and remember
your dumbbells should be in line with
your chest nine down ten plus five more
up one two three last two more
four and five good now just drop your
dumbbells let's get into glute bridge
March okay so still in the same position
lift your butt up okay squeeze and now
one leg at a time alternating up tap up
good crunch and feel your lower abs
working as well three let's go for
fifteen for maintaining a high position
five six seven good halfway there as
high as you can
nine ten hi hi imagine there's a string
pulling your belly button okay so that's
how you should be lifting your butt last
two more whoo last one more and good
rest it out now choose your option
either do this workout with a pair of
dumbbells or no dumbbells this is my
current favorite workout so let's go
dumbbells both in front of you spread it
open open spreading wings into a fly
bring it together bring you back into a
pullover and crunch up good back down
gently do not jerk pull it back crunch
up control and spread good let's go for
fifteen three nice you remember to
engage your corrugate it's not just
about the momentum helping you up engage
your core
five
up six squeeze your chest pull over
through the side of a chest working
seven good bring it back up
nice do not rush the workout it is more
important that you get it right
up straight spread keep your elbows bent
slightly squeeze your chest pull it back
up nine spread squeeze and ten good come
on give me five more okay this is the
end of the second set
pull it up good up hold it for two
counts and lower yourself down control
spread it three more right
you are strong you're towards the end of
the second set and after this we have
one more set to go up one more okay
spread it spread spread squeeze bring it
back pull it over and drop the dumbbells
very well done so that was two circuits
done one more to go drink some water
he was a fighter wipe your sweat and
let's end the final circuit strong
hahaha I would say these are actually
all of my favorite legs glutes apps and
even chest workout because it involves
compound movements therefore you're
recruiting a lot of big muscles and it
is really effective for burning fat and
also toning up
okay so right let's get back up enough
of talking let's and the final circuit
strong you know the movement and I want
you to do this together with me fifteen
repetitions okay nothing less than
fifteen and your goal is to stay as low
as you can keep it low all right let's
go start by moving your right leg and
engaging your left leg okay ready stand
shoulder width apart toes pointed
forward knees nice and soft
let's go squat down and lunge back good
we're going for fifteen okay two three
count with me for good
count with me fine and what's that ten
more ten nine good eight keep it strong
feel laughs like burning seven six
you got four more five mm no you're four
oh four three two last one nice deep
squat one and oh my gosh
shake it out remember we have two Lakes
devil we're working on the other Lake
now okay forward ready or not let's go
squat down left leg back and lunch good
my right leg is stronger so if you're
just like me you should feel that this
side is slightly easier for five ten
more ten nine
eight hence I like this workout because
it really focuses on one leg at a time
six five four three last two two last
one one and whoa okay check it out if
you want to give your butt a little bit
of pat okay and now let's get down onto
all false floating kicks all right
remember do not arch or do not hunched
okay it's very important that you keep
your back flat all right now let's get
up hover one leg back kick it it's not
about lifting too high or too low okay
straight line bring it back kick it and
bring it back good so do not move or
twist your hips too much three four five
squeeze right at the end six squeeze and
only bring it back good seven eight very
nice kick it out nine ten plus five more
1 2 plus 3 3 4 plus 1 and hope I can see
my legs burning it's all alright one
more side okay shake it out a little bit
check it out and now let's get up hover
and take it back one two steady nice and
steady
put your pumps into the floor relax the
shoulders for nice keep a core tight
five six
very good core tight back back seven
eight you're halfway there breathe five
more to go
one two that's three more three come
with me four last one five oh good job
okay right no let's work on our upper
body single eight push up to downward
dog okay you're strong okay are you with
me we're halfway there
this is our final circuit all right
let's go seven on each side
let's go up high plank lift one leg off
push-up and kick it back squeeze squeeze
and down again bring your chest as close
to the floor as possible
three up good you should through the
squeeze right at the top squeeze for one
count and bring it back down five very
nice okay so straight legs okay do you
know twist on one side one more and good
back down and now let's switch side all
right hi peg right leg up one kick it
back squeeze look in between your legs
to squeeze good Pike up as high as you
can
very nice
you are strong okay
three more
I can feel your burn and that is what we
want every time we push beyond our
limits that's when we grow and progress
last one and now let's flip over bridge
chest press grab a pair of dumbbells
let's go final sad you can always push
and challenge yourself that little more
okay so dumbbells both up spread it open
lift your butt up the glutes up squeeze
it ready always in line with the chest
bring it back down tap and push it up
okay good very nice so toast points of
forward do not open your legs to wide
okay keep your knees pointed forward as
well four and squeeze five so control
down and up five six good there you go
control up seven squeeze lift your butt
up feel lower back working and engaging
at the same time seven halfway there
eight squeeze higher up higher come on
do not drop now nine if you feel that
you're dipping come on lift it up now
ten good last five one control the
dumbbells okay your wrist should not be
twisted keep your palms facing forward
to last three squeeze your gluts three
last two four one more down up and back
down good now drop the dumbbells put
them together and now let's get into
glute bridge much again arms gently by
your side just supporting and relaxing
your neck okay
and now let's get up into a bridge and
now alternate one that's one okay to
crunch and feel low abs working three
self-intro do not rush the worker for
it's not about rushing to work out but
rather it's about engaging every muscle
fiber 5 for your lower abs for your hip
flexor working 6 good high up 7 halfway
there
8 9 up 10 squeeze 5 more 1 2 last three
3 two more for up last one 5 ha and now
drop back down my favorite workout which
has to be your favorite workout as well
okay so grab your dumbbells lie back
down knees pointed up toes pointed
forward let's get into fly crunches are
you ready
yeah let's go so spread your wings
squeeze it
pull it back and crunch up nice tap
gently on your knees chest level pull it
back and crunch up as high as you can
nice remember chest level ok chest
squeeze and up again that's three four
pull back breathe out as you come up
okay so breathe in breathe out breathe
in and breathe out five nice in out in
out six good ten you feel your abs work
inking of your chest working can if your
back working as well that's right we're
working on entire body good seven back
up
eight nice and control okay
pumps facing each other keep your wrist
solid and strong nine pull it back your
laps spreading and punch up tan again a
few pullback you should get the stretch
on your back the side of your chest and
crunch up last five more one pull back
last form okay if you can figure the
burn do not stop right now we stop when
we're done we don't stop when you're
tired let's work on those chest and
eventually you will start to see results
lift some weights because trust me it
will help a lot to tone up on your body
up last two more okay do not be afraid
to lift it will only help you to lean up
and look even better it will not make
you look bulky that's two more pull back
up one more okay one more spread it
squeeze pull it back and crunch up well
done so now just got back up drop the
dumbbells ah and that is the end of
three seconds to turn up on your chest
and see your butt
well done now let's just cool down with
some really gentle stretches okay I want
you to just roll your shoulders forward
and back we've worked a lot on your
chest your shoulders and we just want to
release all the tension okay so release
forward
and if you can get into big circles
bring you forward and I'll bring you
back and I'll just slowly stand up and
just gently twist side to side good just
gently twist release your hips and just
release everything very good and I'll
just shake it out I want you to just
step slightly wider than shoulder-width
apart and just gently twist and look and
bend to one side okay and just look up
feel the stretch along your waist and
now let's switch the other side and just
reach
good and now just if you can't balance
yourself just stack your right leg on
top of your left leg
okay and I want to just bend and just
reach down okay this was stretch on your
clues or if you want to just slowly bend
your knees to stretch on your groups if
you need to you can pull onto something
in front of you okay good I just look
straight ahead stretch your right
and I'll just straighten your leg cross
your right leg over your left and just
reach down and you should feel the
stretch along your hamstrings okay if
you can't touch the floor then just hold
the back of your legs and now the other
side so left leg on top of your right
okay again find your balance lift it
higher up and just lower yourself down
he won't be in the same position very
nice and bring a heart rate down
find that inner peace because you've
done so well you completed the entire
workout and now cross over and just
reach down and stretch your hamstrings
okay and I just want you to step wider I
went to just bend your knees and just
spread your feet apart spread your legs
apart and just place both hands in
between and push and spread your legs
apart you should feel the stretch on
inner thighs this is a really good inner
thigh stretch it is so good for those of
you who might be struggling with this
movement you can always just come up
slightly okay if not get into a nice
deep squat and I just reach down and
just straighten both legs
and now go to your right side and just
reach
and change go to your left and reach
good that is the end of your workout if
you're sweating and feeling strong well
be sure to give this video a thumbs up
share this video and be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more workout videos fitness tips as
well as recipes and guys you have been
requesting for daily life workout videos
and that's why I've created my new
fitness app called phew
be sure to download it on the App Store
or go to field live.com you will be able
to get access to unlimited live classes
every single day and I can assure you
you will be able to hit your fitness
goal faster and stand a chance to also
win the all-new Fitbit charge 3 just by
signing up to my app go and check it out
ok